Milwaukee's police chief revealed
officers were disciplined over a
controversial altercation with NBA
player sterling Brown newly released
body cam video shows the incident in
January that started with a parking
violation officers can be seen subduing
Brown and using a stun gun on him the
video appears to contradict an initial
police account that reportedly said
Brown was uncooperative Markham Morgan
is outside Milwaukee Police Headquarters
demarco good morning no we're good
morning to you this is not the first
time the Milwaukee Police Department has
been the focus of questionable use of
force sterling Brown now says he plans
to file a lawsuit sometime next week to
hopefully prevent something like this
from happening again in the near future
our department conducted an
investigation into the incident which
revealed members acted inappropriately
and those members were recently
disciplined on Wednesday newly appointed
Milwaukee police chief Alphonso Morales
apologized for his officers actions and
the January incident it started as what
police described as a routine check
around 2:00 a.m. I'm told a police
officer had spotted NBA player Sterling
Browns vehicle parked across two
handicapped lanes at a Walgreens parking
lot I got up in yo face right really at
first Brown can be seen calmly talking
to police
but once backup arrives the situation
intensifies is thrown to the ground it
was he was briefly booked in jail but
released a short time later no charges
were filed hours after the incident the
Milwaukee Bucks rookie played in an NBA
game with bruises on his face after the
game he refused to comment on what
happened the case has placed added
pressure on a department already under
scrutiny a 2016 riots broke out after an
officer shot and killed Seville Smith
after a traffic stop Smith had a gun but
in a split-second decision and officer
shot and killed him after Smith
apparently tossed his weapon aside as
last year the city settled a lawsuit for
2.3 million dollars for the 2014 killing
of dontre Hamilton a mentally ill man
who was agitated by an officer's
unlawful pat-down the officer shot
Hamilton fort
times during their altercation Brown
released a statement yesterday saying
and I quote what should have been a
simple parking ticket it's turned into
an attempt at police intimidation
followed by the unlawful use of physical
force as for the officers involved the
police chief has not said how they were
disciplined Gill yeah very disturbing
story there thank you very much to Marco